♪ ♪
>> Greg: LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS.
MIKE BLOOMBERG IS PICKING UP
STEAM DESPITE NOT UNDERSTANDING
HOW TO PET A DOG.
NO, YOU DO NOT SHAKE THE DOG’S
FACE LIKE HUMAN HAND.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: OH, HE WAS JUST
PLAYING WITH IT.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT PLAYING.
LET’S SEE IT ONE MORE TIME.
LOOK.
>> Kennedy: VERY POLITE DOG.
>> Greg: HE IS SHAKING HIS
FACE.
I THINK HE LOST THE PETA VOTE.
MEANWHILE, THE TINY SCAR YOU GOT
FROM THE VACCINE YOU GOT AS A
KID, HE NEVER GOES AWAY.
LIKE HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
URGE.
>> I STILL FEEL THE URGE BECAUSE
I FEEL LIKE THE 2016 ELECTION
WAS REALLY AN AUDIT TIME AND AN
ODD OUTCOME.
THE MORE WE LEARN THE MORE IT
SEEMS TO BE THE CASE.
>> Greg: RIGHT NOW
BERNIE SANDERS IS HOT AND HAS
THE MOST ENTHUSIASTIC BASE.
ONE OF HILLARY OR ANYONE KNOCKS
HIM ASIDE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE VOTERS ARE
GOING TO DO?
THE GOING TO VOTE FOR MIKE OR
JOE?
THEY JUST WOULD ASSUME VOTE FOR
TRUMP.
ALMOST AS HILARIOUS AS THE
ANTI-SANDERS DAMS TURNING ON
BERNIE.
THEY ARE ATTACKING HIM FOR THIS.
>> I THINK I WILL PROBABLY VOTE
FOR BERNIE BY HIM AS A HUMAN
BEING WHEN I WAS HANGING OUT
WITH HIM, I BELIEVE IN HIM, I’D
LIKE HIM A LOT.
HE HAS BEEN INSANELY CONSISTENT
HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
HE’S BASICALLY BEEN SAYING THE
SAME THING, BEEN FOR THE SAME
THING HIS WHOLE LIFE.
AND THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS A
VERY POWERFUL STRUCTURE.
>> Greg: ROGAN IS RIGHT.
BERNIE HAS BEEN INSANELY
CONSISTENT.
INSANELY CONSISTENCY WRONG.
WHILE HE EXCELS, BERNIE ONLY
EMBRACES THE WORLD’S LOSERS.
BUT ROGAN IS A COMET, MADE A
BILLION JOKES OVER HIS LIFETIME.
SOME STUPID, SOME EVEN AWFUL.
THAT MEANS YOU ARE PRIME FOR THE
CANCELING OF YOUR OWN CAREER BUT
YOUR OWN SINS CAN INFECT THOSE
AROUND YOU LIKE SOMEONE YOU
INDOORS, LIKE BERNIE.
OFFENSIVENESS BECOMES
TRANSMISSIBLE LIKE A VIRUS.
HATE THE SIN, LOVE THE SINNER?
IT WAS ONE OF RELIGION’S
GREATEST HITS.
NOW THE CENTER IS THE SIN,
MAKING FORGIVENESS IMPOSSIBLE.
AT LEAST IN THIS ENDLESS GAME OF
GRIEVANCE WHACK-A-MOLE.
IT’S NOT HARD TO SEE WHERE THIS
LEADS.
A GUY NAMED TRUMP RAN IN AND
2016 ON A PC-KILLING HORUS.
IF THE LEFT CONTINUES ITS MOB
ACTION, HE’S GOING TO DO IT
AGAIN.
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE DOG EXPERT,
WAS THAT THE PROPER WAY TO PET A
DOG?
SHAKING THE UPPER ROOF OF HIS
MOUTH?
>> Dana: I THINK HE WAS JUST
PLAYING WITH THE DOG.
YOU WANT TO TEACH KIDS THAT
BEFORE YOU GO AND PUT YOUR HAND
AND A DOG’S MOUTH YOU WANT TO
BASICALLY LET THEM SMELL YOUR
HAND TO SEE IF IT’S OKAY.
IT’S LIKE ASKING PERMISSION FOR
A HUG, YOU KNOW THE WHOLE --
>> Greg: I THINK HE SHOULD’VE
SIGNED A WAIVER.
AT THAT DOG IS IN THERAPY NOW.
HE HAS A THERAPY HUMAN.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW HOW SHE SAYS
THE MORE WE LEARN ABOUT THE 2016
ELECTION, WHY SHE HAS THE URGE
NOW.
THAT IS ALL ABOUT, THEY STILL
BELIEVE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
COST THEM THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> Kennedy: AND JAMES COMEY,
AND MISOGYNY, AND HUSBANDS
TELLING THEIR WIVES HOW TO VOTE.
I WATCHED HILLARY CLINTON AND I
ACTUALLY HAVE PITY FOR HER.
THIS WEEK IN
"THE NEW YORK POST," THEY
PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE THAT THE
FDA IS APPROVING MORE MDMA TO BE
USED FOR PTSD IN THERAPEUTIC
SETTINGS, WHICH COULD BE
FANTASTIC BECAUSE
HILLARY CLINTON CLEARLY SUFFERS
FROM PTSD.
FOR THAT, I TRULY FEEL BAD FOR
HER BECAUSE SHE WAKES UP EVERY
DAY, EVERY DAY’S GROUNDHOG DAY.
IT IS A LIVING NIGHTMARE FOR HER
AND THE ONLY WAY SHE CAN WAKE UP
AND MARY ANNIE McDOWELL’S IF
SHE WINS THE ELECTION AND SHE
HAS TO SOMEHOW FIGURE OUT A
WAY -- BEFORE IT WAS HAVING TO
ELBOW ELIZABETH WARREN OUT OF
THE WAY BUT SHE IS ALREADY
IMPLODING SO SHE MAY HAVE HER
WISH.
REVIVE A BROKERED CONVENTION.
I MISS ANDY McPHAIL.
WHERE IS SHE?
>> Kennedy: COME ON OUT.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, HILLARY
LATER SAID THAT SHE WILL SUPPORT
ANY NOMINEE THERE IS, SO THAT
MEANS SHE MAY NOT BE RUNNING BUT
THERE WOULD BE A BROKERAGE
CONVENTION WHERE THEY DROP OUT
OF THE SKY TOGETHER.
>> Juan: THAT IS YOUR FANTASY?
>> Jesse: WOMEN DROPPING FROM
THE SKY.
>> Greg: YES, THANK YOU, GOD.
>> Jesse: IT’S NOT MY FANTASY,
IT’S YOURS.
>> Juan: WHOSE HAND IS DANA
HAVE TO HOLD HERE?
I WAS INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU’RE
SAYING ABOUT JOE ROGAN, THAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT THE WHOLE
CANCEL CULTURE THING BECAUSE I
DON’T THINK ROGAN IS ANY
RIGHT-WINGER.
NO RIGHT-WINGER IS GOING TO
ENDORSE BERNIE SANDERS!
THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, PEOPLE
THINK OF HIM AS THE DARK WEB
INTELLECT AND HE SAYS SOME
REALLY AWFUL JOKES, HOMOPHOBIC,
RACIST TYPE STUFF.
BUT THE POINT IS, YOU SEE THIS
ON BOTH SIDES, THE PURITY TESTS.
IF THE PHONE CALL WASN’T
PERFECT, THEN YOU ARE NOT LOYAL
TO DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOUR 99% WITH HIM, YOU MIGHT
AS WELL BE 0%.
TO ME, THIS IS WHERE POLITICS IS
GOING.
ALL OR NOTHING AND DRIVEN BY THE
FAR LEFT AND FAR RIGHT.
I THINK ROGAN, THE IDEA THAT HE
SUPPORTS BERNIE, I DON’T SEE IT
AS THAT SURPRISING.
YOU KNOW WHO HE IS.
>> Jesse: HE IS COLLATERAL
DAMAGE BECAUSE THE KNIVES ARE
OUT FOR BERNIE.
HE’S A BIGGER THREAT TO THE
DEMOCRATS THAN DONALD TRUMP.
HOW HAVE THE DEMOCRATS HANDLED
2016?
THINK ABOUT HOW THEY HANDLED A
LANDSLIDE LOSS WITH
BERNIE SANDERS.
IT’S GOING TO BE UGLY AND HE’S
GOING TO WANT TO ABOLISH I.C.E.,
RAISE MIDDLE-CLASS TAXES, BAND
FRACKING, DONALD TRUMP IS GOING
TO HAVE A FIELD DAY WITH BERNIE
AND THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IT.